ENNIS.BY
OTTAWA.
YOU GET PLAYERS TO THE NET,
PUCK GOES ININ
HE LOST HIS NET, REALLY GOOD
JOB THOUGH ON THE AT
>> Brian: HE ALSO HAS A SHUT
OUT TH
BRAYDEN POINT IN THE CORNER.
IN COMES HEDMAN TOARTEM ZUB.
BANKS ANCHEROV OF THE
GOLAN NOW BRAYDEN POINT HAS A
GOAL.
THE CATCH OTTAWA WITH A THE NET
IS RADDYSH.
TIPPED TO THE LINE AND THEN
BUMPED OUT BY OTTAWA. FROM.
POSSIBLY.
THE LIGHTNING HAVE GOT IT BACK
WITH HIM.
NOW IT IS 2-2.
CHECKS BEHIND HIM AGAIN  BUT
HE'S GOT THE PUCK.
MISS ONE HIGH WIDER SHORT SIDE
BUT HE DOES NOT MISS VERY OFTEN
ALIVE, KEEP THE
MURRAY.
HERE
SO FACE-OFF, WON CLEANLY BY
SEASON.
HEDMAN BACK TO KUCHEROV,
A LOT.
ANOTHER MULTIPOINT GAME ARTEM Z
GOOD PLAY BY BROWN TO BREAK IT
UP.
McDONOUGH.AS A HECK OF A SAFE B
MATT MURRAY BUT HE NEEDED HELP.
HE WAS ABLE TOTO CENTER, NEAR S
COLIN WHITE, BACK INTO THE
CORNER Y, LOTS OF HANDLE.THERE
AGAIN.
EVENTUALLY OF THE BEST WRIST
SHOT EVER.
AND HE JUST CATCA 514.
NOW A SIX ON FOUR, TO  KATCHOUK
AND THAT IS WHERE HEHE